hey everybody and welcome to an
anomalous wild ride with sto and if
you're wondering what anomalous means it
is that which deviates from the normal
the standard and the expected and that
is what you're going to get today
because there have been new developments
in the
UAP UFO world of phenomena and we have
all dare say breaking news from the
foremost leading expert in these matters
Jeremy corbel so without any further Ado
let's get into
it ladies and Gentlemen people of the
Universe I bring to you again Jeremy
Corbell and again we have a special
guest cohost the star of Jackass it is
Dave England woohooo I'm the star of
Jackass the star not one of the stars
the star y just clarify and speaking of
stars you have Scott Randolph that's
right and we're talking about UFOs in
the skies yeah um last week we uh we we
might have rubbed a lot of people the
wrong way what' you do we uh we
suggested why you read some of the
comments I Vinnie told me about it the
thousands of comments they're like l l l
right um but but hey who knows maybe
that was good for engagement and if
anybody listened to what we talked about
we were suggesting that uh Aaron roders
and Cat Williams might have had a rough
week but everybody universally agrees
that Cat Williams got the dub I came
around on that and there was a lot of
push back saying Aaron roders did not
catch an L but hey you know what yeah
well all of the comments said that Aaron
Rogers didn't take an L all of them then
I guess then I guess we're wrong and
I'll I'll just admit that I'm wrong
again
you okay and uh Vinnie um bless his
heart despite the fact that he's getting
married uh this weekend will have gotten
married last week um not missing a
podcast old
Vinnie he's up there in the front he's
getting married on Monday uh
congratulations brother congratulations
Vinnie but enough enough about that get
into the UFOs thing um Jeremy since the
last time we saw you we've become
buddies we shoot each other texts and
stuff you sent me a text about this TMZ
presents
UFO uh Revolution yeah on tuby on Tu
yeah yeah that trailer was insane thanks
man I watched the trailer I've been
watching the the series on tuby we had
to talk to you again I think you have
UFO disease I think that you had have an
addiction to UFOs and there are groups
for that uh I will run that for you we
can do facetimes weekly or daily
whatever you need um I'm stoked to see
you again man uh I did not expect to see
you again so soon right this is the
first time I'm sitting down long form to
talk about this it's been a hell of a
week you know I've been planning for
more than three and a half years to try
to get some of this information out the
the special is really cool like the UFO
revolution of course I haven't watched
the whole thing but I saw the edits and
you know it was really
personal for me and and I haven't really
let people in before on that but I think
what it does is it kind of peels back
the layer of like you know what does it
mean to do this and and and how do
you get it done uh and I think that's
important for people to see because it
it kind of demystifies a lot of what
people think you know who's this guy
this idiot bearded guy obtaining
military filmed UFO footage so I think
it it kind of peels back that layer and
lets people in a little bit and I think
that's powerful because they can let go
of stupid ideas
I mean do you uh I saw you I was just
watching the Y files you you know the
YouTube channel dud I've seen that
referenc you yesterday they're playing
your Clips on the episode last night
yeah yeah when I st the one with the the
guy got the little
goldfish love that yeah yeah
I've seen it I love it that's so cool I
just don't have time to like like when
you were talking earlier it's like
hieroglyphics to me I I I don't
understand popular culture I don't watch
a lot of stuff but I have seen the wi
files it's pretty cool wi files is cool
yeah um you mentioned how this uh this
2B three-part series TMZ investigates
TMZ presents yeah UFO Revolution you
said that that it gave a personal yeah
kind of glimpse into your life yeah and
I saw on there that you described how uh
UFO uh it's it's more of a hobby for you
that it's that that you have a job and
that your job isn't about
UFOs yes I mean I it's not a hobby it's
an obsession I'm an addict for UFOs like
you now U but it yeah so I think that is
one of the things it it reveals in the
show and again I have to watch the Final
Cut but yeah I mean that I have put more
money and time and just you know energy
into investigating this topic than I'll
ever get back out from it um yeah I do
have a job I'm self-employed but I mean
look I've been self-employed since I was
you know 16 years old you know doing
Jiu-Jitsu and that kind of thing and
then all the way up through uh I mean as
polishing silver and painting the braces
off of my enemies and their zits when
you didn't have Photoshop and I was
working in a photo lab in a basement for
somewhere to buy a Mustang but uh my
whole life I've been self-employed so my
wife and I got into real estate the
smartest thing I ever did was listen to
her but also invest what I earned all
those years of training jiujitsu and
teaching Jiu-Jitsu into property so I
guess they revealed that a little bit in
the episode that yeah this is not like
how I put food on my table right you
said you're out more money than you put
in yeah I mean look I it's hard for
people to grasp if they've never made a
documentary in the way in which I do but
like I don't get paid to come on these
interviews I I don't get paid to do news
hits um my films some the bobazar film
took me legitimately 9 years so imagine
all that time and it it's you know once
we started filming for that that's a
whole another thing that was rapid Pace
but all the trips all the work getting
to know people moving that on yeah I'll
never recover all of that uh I'm not
complaining that's just how it is so I
think that's important for people to
understand that you know I do this
because I love it and because I want to
understand more and I I'm greedy I'm
selfish I want to know more more than I
want to tell other people people so
that's been my focus for from you know a
long time now and so there's stuff that
you haven't gotten out and that it's
come it came out in this UF UFO
Revolution couple things have come out
in this yeah what I haven't gotten out I
just haven't gotten out yet but yeah we
got two new or three new major assets I
call them products so military filmed
UFO footage or imagery and in this
series you know I my priority is to
protect sources even if they don't
protect themselves and that is that is a
a delicate dance in this series I was
able to release uh two very important
UFO
cases how do you know that their actual
military couldn't you photoshop like
crosshairs and yeah sure you could
switch it to Thermal to not but like do
you have a some sort of a a way to sus
that out yeah why did it take me 3 and
1/2 years to feel confident putting this
out to the public because yeah I'm
fastidious is the word someone just
taught me with my work I don't know what
it means it basically means like
attention to detail but like yeah man uh
you could fake anything these days and
that's the problem right you could fake
any footage so I usually and typically
require about three times that I get a
piece of footage and I get it
anonymously and I set it up that way I
don't want a source that I'm talking
with I don't want to know who gave me
video that's a legal issue so I make
sure they send it to me does that not uh
call into question The credibility if
you don't I mean you know the source
you're just not going to share the
source so but it's not a source see
that's the thing what I'm saying is uh
it takes usually about three times for
me to get a product right like a
military filmed video then what I do is
through my own channels not through
connections that sources give me I I
mean I have sources in the dod the doj
the CIA the FBI I mean you name it and
I'm not bragging I'm I'm actually making
a threat right now I O I I I no no
because here's the deal here's the deal
I'll know if there's and so any
engagement I've ever had with agencies
they know too that I will know if
there's I'll find out if there's
an active investigation of course there
are active investigations into what
George nap and I have released and good
for them it's an important job the idea
that if people leak stuff you got to
plug those leaks I get it but as a
journalist the First Amendment the idea
of freedom of press for public good so I
feel maybe I'm ignorant but I feel
protected because everybody I've ever
talked to in agencies their biggest fear
is that other countries will compromise
will blackmail so they can get
before I vetted it for National Security
I've never done nothing wrong so the
whole idea is when you get this stuff
how do you vet it how do you know how do
you know it's not fake there's a lot of
ways to do that but here's what I tell
people first conversation if you're a
source and you call me I say have
patience on me don't give up on me I'm
on Cosmic time not on your time
seriously and I develop relationships
over years with people I then do my own
vetting through my own sources not
through who sources give me sources and
then I bring it to George knp when I
feel it's a good case and he does his
own process through his own contacts
that he's made for over 40 years if I
put something out you can bet your
ass that it is legit and that it
is worth putting out to the public for
debate
very cool um when you sent me the
trailer for The the 2B three-part
series um there's kind of a lot of
emphasis on people being in danger
people's lives being threatened people
David gush that right and the last time
we spoke to you uh you seemed pretty
laidback about about the whole idea of
being a Target being in danger you know
like um um in the in the series itself
you you said that you're safe because
you're a
journalist if you want to be safe I
think we can all agree that being a
journalist with Integrity might help but
what I think really helps more than
anything is to take supplements that
boost all of your body's function and
the best supplements in the market
brought to you by momentus these are
supplements that can be trusted because
they're used by over 90% of the teams in
the NFL they're developed and used by
the legendary Andrew huberman and yours
truly steo now when you go to Liv
mous.com you'll see that they have all
these different bundles of supplements
for different things like sleep you got
to know sleep is humongously important
to me so this little sleep bundle right
here is my bedtime 30 to 60 minutes
before I go to bed so that I get maximum
REM sleep and you know how important REM
sleep is and I'll have you know that I'm
sleeping better than ever thanks to this
stuff but to start off my day I've got
everything to boost my cognitive ability
the alpha GPC the
tyrosine and omega3 which is for brain
health and I added in acetal lcarnitine
for metabolism and muscle support so
there you have it folks and if you want
to get 20% off your order you go to Liv
mous.com that's
LV m o m n t u s.com and use the promo
code steo again that gets you 20% off
your order and you're in the supplement
game with the best in the business so
join me and Andrew huberman by doing
that and let's get back to
it do you still feel that way if you
remember specifically what I told you is
that I use that term as a shield you
know I'm a journalist because I say I am
because I break news because I bring
stuff forward I don't know the letter of
the law but I know the spirit of the law
so you know look in one sense it's a
front don't with me I will push
that button but on so so I'm not
minimizing that I'm not minimizing what
I have heard from sources I'm not
minimizing what they've experienced
there are active Inspector General
complaints against what has been done to
people like David grush and it is
diabolical and it it involves physical
danger me myself everybody seems to
pretend they're my friend so the thing
is is I've never um I don't feel the
need to publicly talk about the the
pressure that I feel you know in
protecting sources and myself right I'm
not going to minimize it though this is
a secret and it's it's treated at a UFOs
is treated at a level higher than
weapons of mass destruction meaning that
there's a threat somehow in the mind of
intelligence agencies how they come at
how they try to silence people it can be
compromising journalists like just even
on Twitter and like getting them to like
try to discredit people character
assassination which we saw with David
grush yeah with his PTSD so
stupid he got over it a lot of people
murder themselves because of you
know PTSD
they they're so limp dick these these
kinds of things but there's more there
there's other ways that people can be
pressured and other ways can be
threatened and yeah George Napp and I
have our own stories and one day we we
will tell that and I've documented
everything but I I don't think that's
important right now what's important is
people to Have Courage how we treat our
whistleblowers right now is going to
determine what we learn about the UFO
topic within the next year so they did
show that a little bit in the series
like you said but but I I don't dwell on
it man you know I feel like if you're
doing the right thing or you're trying
to you know then you're on the right
path okay what about all these threats
and danger is it all from the US
government or other other entities or
yeah man it's it's really Dynamic so I'm
going to try to answer you like really
directly um I have to be I have to dance
a little bit but I'm going try to answer
you really directly there are many
interests to and I'm going to say this
real clear shape the emerging UAP
narrative in quotes imagine that in a
document from an intelligence agency
okay so what that means is the the
threats are like well is my family going
to be okay am I going to lose a
clearance right so for people that are
in the military you know will I be
defamed to the point like they tried
with David grush where no one's going to
hire the guy always buy someone
representing the US government I mean
it's not like Elizabeth Warren's
assistant is coming after you right so
no yeah because who are the holders of
the secrets remember remember a lot of
this technology is said to have been put
into Private Industry so think like you
think about like big tobacco I mean they
did some diabolical to people that
were blowing the whistle this is more
important and bigger than that so when
you move something in Private Industry
they have their own kind of Rules of
Engagement so is it always the US
government no most everybody in the US
government wants to know what's going on
but when you move things into Private
Industry
and you give them power they can operate
by different rules now of course they
are defense
contractors right but that that those
threats that pressure that shut up
silence don't talk about this we're
going to Mock You it comes
from mechanisms with within Private
Industry it feeds down to social media
and then people are co-opted by our
intelligence agencies do you remember
project mocking bird that came out uh
back in the day in Congress sounds
vaguely familiar it's where they opt
journalists where they grab them they
pay them or they threaten them the CIA
was doing this and this is like not a
conspiracy this is like a real thing
that happened and it came out back in
the day with a a very important event
that occurred in Congress which we'll
talk about later but that is real and
that happens now personally I have
something wrong with my brain I am just
I dropped my last a long time ago I
am not going to endanger National
Security but I am definitely going to
pursue this and tell the truth so so I'm
not too worried about it but I've seen
other people harmed what they did to
David grush was horrible but the
thing is he was ready for it first
conversation I had with him is what dirt
are they going to pull up and how are
they going to hurt you because they're
gonna if what you're saying is true
they're gonna he came to me and George
first now for anybody who's not clear
David grush is the guy who we all saw
testify in front of Congress yeah saying
that they they have uh nonhuman bio
biologics you got it meaning meaning
that he testified under oath that the US
government is in possession of actual
Anonymous aircraft plus non-human
biologic meaning like uh effectively Ali
alien Pilots of of uh these nom
are they alive or dead still so they
would be dead right first of all check
this out first of all the reason we use
non-human intelligence when we're
talking about this is because we don't
want to make presumptions is it ET
extraterrestrial is it extradimensional
a could just be from from where just a
hidden intelligence that's called
ultraterrestrial right like uh some
people that have been here longer than
us are they piloting the craft sometimes
they are are the craft run with with an
artificial intelligence so it's a drone
that's a great word for a drone sure all
and yes and of the above yes and Time
Travelers extemporal so so we could go
through there's like four or five big
theories on where these things come from
but why you say non-human intelligence
is because you're just trying to like
leave the door open and not make an
assumption like an idiot right you know
where it comes from right now there are
people that claim that they know and all
that stuff and I will tell you this the
craft that we have obtained our
government specifically the DIA the head
of the DIA program defense intelligence
so the DIA is an intelligence agency
it's called the defense intelligence
agency it was admitted that they had a
UFO program you heard about it in the
New York Times They called it a
different name but you heard about it
that was the 2017 article yeah a tip
they called it right but the the main
program the mother program was called
ASAP I had the head of the DIA UFO
program come on my podcast with George
naap called weapon
and he admitted that they had a craft
that they obtained a craft just one he
admitted to one and they breached the
whole of it it wasn't made by us wasn't
China wasn't Russia so they call it
non-human intelligence right because
we're not exactly sure or I'm not
exactly sure where the the pilots or The
Operators of The Craft are from but that
is fact he got authorized to say it
through a doser request which just means
he asked the government hey what can I
talk about you know I'm writing books
so but he admitted it on the show and
that's just one where he found it well
he didn't find it he was the the head of
the program studying it so you got
people studying the craft but let me get
back to the point which is that where
are they
from what is their
intent those are the big questions but
we can't even get there unless we come
to consensus reality that we got these
craft and I'll tell you something about
the craft and why I think they're not
from here from Earth is because the
structure the way they're built they are
capable of Beyond Interstellar travel so
anybody that's ever worked in these
programs who I do continue to talk to
who are currently in them and people
that have been in them say the craft
themselves are capable of you say faster
than speed faster than light but that's
not the case they're gravitationally
propelled so they warp SpaceTime but
they're capable structurally of moving
you know within solar systems and Beyond
yeah
would be going to other sons and so why
would you make a Ferrari if you're just
you know at home in your driveway never
going to leave the gate right so that
tells me something that tells me they're
probably from another star system but
there might be multiple things going on
there could be some that are like that
and there could be some that are
interdimensional people say I don't know
what that means but I kind of understand
yeah that seems like it makes sense what
what's the leading theory on where
aliens are from well the the lead in
theory from the people that actually
work in these UFO reverse engineering
exploitation programs for derivative
Technologies unpack that right what
they say is that they get conflicting
ideas meaning there might be more than
like one group of other people from
other places coming here so it could be
all of the above in the kitchen sink I
don't know that's what this is all about
if this is real let's start talking
about
it the the idea that I got as far as why
the government takes this so seriously
and why the government's been so
secretive
I kind of just heard the message that
the government was embarrassed to admit
that what they know about this
anomalist uh you know craft all this UFO
stuff is that it is a technology so far
Advanced beyond anything that we as
humans are capable of it defies
everything scientifically that that that
we even understand and as such if this
phenomena was to turn hostile the the
the government is well aware that it
cannot defend its own Skies it cannot
defend its own people that like if if
this
anomalous phenomena turns hos they they
even say aliens whatever somewhere some
else yeah they can just they can kick
our ass there's nothing we can do about
it we're at their Mercy for sure sure
and the government was embarrassed to
admit that and and that's why they
wanted to keep a lid on it all that
that's what I it would cause Mass
hysteria too if they announc hey there's
aliens and they could take us out at any
moment now let's be realistic causing
Mass hysteria does not have to be a bad
thing if you've got the right idea then
why not build the right website and the
right eCommerce business to take
advantage of mass hysteria in a positive
way and that's what Shopify is all about
it is the gold standard for websites no
matter what stage your business is in
even if you don't have a business it is
the easiest and most professional way to
build a website and once you have done
that it is the gold standard in setting
up business for your website I use it so
much check it out I've got this little
plaque for
having a 100,000 orders completed
through Shopify ato.com very proud of
that I'm very grateful for Shopify
because no matter what it is you're
trying to accomplish Shopify is the way
to make it happen and they've got a $1
per month trial period that you cannot
go wrong with so you go to shopify.com
steo all lowercase you try this out for
$1 a month so that you can find out
firsthand how easy it is to build a
website with them and how
completely comprehensive it is to
integrate any facet for e-commerce
business I can't recommend it enough
it's the secret to my success and this
$1 trial period offer is yours if you go
to shopify.com
sto all lowercase so get to it and let's
get back to
it so then the like we can deduce that
since that's the case that it is in fact
not hostile that there is let me sh let
me talk about the different sides of the
coins on that right like at least three
sides right um
the original reason for not only the
secrecy but the laugh Factor you know
making people smart people don't talk
about this they never said they didn't
exist if you go back to the old
interviews that you see in the series
they start with these like news segments
they always say they're not a threat to
National Security whatever they are
they're not saying they don't exist now
the government has admitted they do
exist why would you keep it secret let
me defend both sides
first if you're like technologically
advancing you're like this is a new
phenomenon we could get a derivative
technology and we would be ahead of the
game whoever wins I mean or whoever
discovers how to replicate this Tech
they win game over they will be
the power most powerful Nation on planet
Earth instantaneously you know how the
atom bomb it was a it was it was used to
stop the war that was that was the idea
right you show the power everybody
pauses Humanity pauses and they go oh
let's not keep doing this so
whoever gets the ability to replicate
these propulsion systems it can be
weaponized and if you have a weapon like
that it's game over so if I was the
government I'd be like holy we
already got the mechanisms in place
because of the atomic program to keep
this compartmentalized and secret
so let's do that till we figure out
what's going on because we need the
technological advantage so that we don't
get duped by another country who is also
working on it China and Russia and but
also what about that you know like the
atomic bomb could have been who's to say
that wasn't provided by aliens well
let's let's get to that kind of idea in
a second let's let's go through why you
keep a secret I want to defend both
sides so there are good people in the US
government that thought like that that
were like oh dude we better get a handle
on this because because we could be
screwed National Security and then
you've got other people people that say
well wait a second here uh to admit that
there is a force there are people that
have craft that can outmaneuver
outperform our greatest Weaponry that we
don't have 360 air dominance 24/7 at all
times globally that is something you
don't want to be telling your enemies or
even your own country so I understand
the secrecy from that point of view
right problem is people keep seeing UFOs
well they was interesting to me was when
the guy said um he's like at what
percentage you know are we allowed to
talk about and he's like 5% so like who
said that no about 5% of UFO sightings
go reported by the Air Force oh hell
yeah I mean I I would say even less than
that I mean because Pilots are seeing
them every day I get calls every day
from people that it would shock the
world it would shock people to know
who's had Direct contact with these UFOs
uh it would really shock people and and
they never coming forward ever because
that Laugh Factory because you know
they' be ridiculed they're not wrapped
so tight well luckily that's a 50s
mentality we're now at the point where
you can say okay I've seen something but
when you have footage infrared thermal
when you have radar and it's not just
Uncle Jim anymore in his airplane being
like I saw something now the sensor
systems the sensor packages are becoming
so just um powerful that we can capture
these things and get so much more data
that's why you're seeing a lot of
military footage from me because it's
what much better than an iPhone so so
back is it though it is because that's
the criticism is that with all of the
advancements of our uh camera technology
still what what the one the one news
reporter said why does it look like
every like a video of UFOs was filmed on
a baked potato yeah so Neil theg grass
Tyson even uh shocked me with his
ignorance on this you know these are
multi-million dollar weapons platforms
not iPhones this is not an Instagram
photo let me just give me a second let
me break this down this is so
important
okay have you seen a whole shitload of
high quality thermal imagery of UFOs
filmed by our government before I
started releasing them back in you know
maybe whatever year I started releasing
them the answer is no you didn't so the
thing is we are not only capturing them
now on all these other platforms but
let's really address the problem here
our technology is getting better first
of all this is an intelligence if they
made these craft in their Advance it's
an intelligence so like I know when
you're trying to record me I know if you
have a nest camera I can see it so I'm
aware of your technology what says
they're not aware of ours and our
Evolution as as human beings the other
thing is the iPhone bro that is not what
you're seeing on the videos I'm
releasing let me explain the difference
you got an iPhone you pull it out shoot
the moon go ahead take a picture see
what you see
right what you're seeing in these videos
is you're seeing this layered sensor
systems so you're seeing Heat Signature
thermal that's the black and white
you're seeing infrared and an infrared
is a light spectrum outside of what the
or it's an amplification of light often
times outside of what the eye can see so
if I take my nvgs night vision goggles
hold them up like that to the sky the
sky is littered with
Suns Stars littered with Suns your eye
can't pick that up but the nvg can so
when you film through that wow you can
see whole spectrums of light you can
even film in the ultraviolet you can get
radar returns you get optic systems are
so powerful so that is a false argument
that people make they don't understand
what they're talking about even Neil
degrass Tyson which really made me sad
we need a voice like him but you know he
needs to like start thinking and not
just talking so here's the deal we are
seeing better footage of UFOs they're
being leaked to me they are thermal
infrared they are in spectrums of light
that are layered there's something
called full motion video which layers
all these spectrums together in color at
night your iPhone can't do that yet so
as we progress with technology and thank
you for letting me explain this and do
this around your patience I appreciate
it we're on Cosmic time you thank you we
are you're going to see a lot
more man they're everywhere the the the
pesky thing about UFOs is they won't go
away is this a good segue to show the
clip of the the the weirdest UFO clip
I've ever seen in my life yeah let's
show it and this has never before seen
yeah it came out in the series yeah and
and Dave you want to check this out over
come over there yeah just play and we'll
narrate over
it this is the that looks like one of
the jellyfish
ones can you
see sit here now for people who
criticize the uh you know resolution the
quality of the video of of UFOs it it
all looks to me a little bit like when
they when they show a footage of drone
strikes from the like you know when when
you see a a missile hit a Target like on
the news and they're showing war footage
it's the same type okay let let me this
is the highest Fidelity footage so the
clearest footage from thermal that
you'll see is from an aerostat which is
a weap or a targeting weapons platform
above these bases to stop incursions
they'll strap like bombs on drones and
these guys are highly trained they're
like this is a they they go through this
training they're like here's what a
trash bag floating in the air looks like
through this thermal sensor here's what
a balloon looks like these guys know
that because they've been trained Ru all
that stuff out I have seen their
training briefings I know for sure so
what what what's interesting to me so
first of all a few things let's break
down you notice how the the video is a
little skewed obviously whoever leaked
it to me and by the way it was leaked to
me multiple times fil the screen yeah
they film the screen and that's probably
in skiff and that's illegal and you know
that's why I protect sources I don't
want to know who sent it to me but I get
it a bunch of times and I start calling
people get firsthand Witnesses so what
you're seeing there it's so funny these
debunkers these are not critics like
debunkers and critics are different
debunkers exclude information to fit
their agenda critics look at something
critically I am way more critical of
videos than people think so what you're
seeing here people are saying oh that's
a smudge on the lens well first of all I
know after 3 and a half years it's not a
smudge on the lens and that was
immediately debunked by yeah dude you
can somebody took the video and you can
see the object rotating so it's like
it's incredible to me the things they'll
say like it's Birds it's uh bird poop on
a lens so it's not that is an object and
it's changing um you know Darkness to
lightness heat it's the cold hot so it's
changing temperature and if you did film
this with an iPhone it would be nice and
crisp and everything but there would be
not that object you wouldn't you
wouldn't see it you would see it would
be black is this night time or daytime
this is night so nobody on the the
that's in the area can see this with
their eye that's one of the trippiest
things so nobody noticed it nobody saw
it in fact an alert went out they shut
off the feed to two other countries I've
talked to everybody that was not
everybody tons of people that were there
that day that night and not only that
but they sent out people with night
vision which is a different spectrum of
lights not thermal and it was invisible
it's not they they they knew where it
was it was invisible so that's like
called sign signature management so that
is a a real problem so this thing is
turning from hot to cold in the thermal
Spectrum couldn't be seen through night
vision which is just a spectrum of light
the human eye can't quite see it's an
amplification of light nobody saw it
also visually no one noticed it the dogs
the people everybody and by the way this
is a this is a base within a base where
this is filmed this this is really lucky
the American Afghanistan so no so this
was um I think I can say now more about
it
this object came in through a base that
was a joint operations base run by the
United States the Navy a couple agencies
and a an aerospace
contractor and the they were the clients
of the base at this time this object
went through this base within a base and
then went out over Lake havania I think
that's how you say it and uh that it was
uh moving out over the water and that's
the footage that I'm release a little
bit more of very soon is like it moving
over the water the thing is is I can't
explain now why where's Lake havania uh
so that is uh right over Iraq so this is
yeah sorry I didn't so the country is
Iraq and it was at a US joint operations
base but a base within a base run by
those contractors and agencies I told
you and nobody's getting in there I'm
not flying a drone in there without it
getting shot the dude
can you believe this guy Scott Randolph
thinks he's going to go and perpetrate
behavior that's frowned upon and expect
to have no consequences whatsoever that
is naive and misguided because I will
tell you if you perpetrate Behavior
that's frowned upon you should expect
consequences and Swift ones at that and
that is why it is so important to
finally drop the bad habit that makes
people look down upon you with a frown
think you know what I'm talking about
and man I've got the way to drop the bad
habit by replacing it with the good one
and it is called fume fume is a
diffusive device which simply flavors
air so you can trade in that dangerous
chemical with flavored air you can trade
in that embarrassing bad habit with a
good one and now candidly I love this so
much much my fume is always in my pocket
and if you see me anywhere ask me if
it's in my say you got your fume in your
pocket and if I don't I will shoot a
little Shout Out video for you and all
your buddies and if I'm honest every
single person who has said do you have
your fil in your pocket even though I
did I shot that video for him anyway
because that's the kind of guy I am I
love it and I think you're going to love
it too and they've got a special deal
for the listeners of the Wild Ride
podcast if you go to Tri fume
that's t r
yfu
m.com SLO and use the promo code steo
you're going to get 10% off your order
and that is in addition to their buy one
get one deal on the flavored cores that
is the core in the middle which flavors
the air you buy one you get one so one
more time go to
tri.com
steo and use the promo code steo to get
on your journey to a healthier happier
you now let's get back to it these guys
on a daily basis assess this they target
with this system you can shoot an
Al-Qaeda or an Isis tire out of a moving
vehicle you can track it and Target it
at 23 miles or more and it's never
failed the system that's why it's so
high fidelity high quality thermal it's
never failed they track it and they blow
up and Return to Sender bombs so if
somebody puts like a bomb on a drone and
flies it over the wall an incursion
right first time the world is ever
seeing an incursion of a true UAP
designated by our government in a
conflict Zone first time we get footage
of that film by the military that's what
you're seeing now the problem is is that
they couldn't lock the system that they
believe it was active jamming the people
that were there that day they believe
that this object was um somehow
inhibiting their targeting system from
blocking so they they had to optically
slew the camera optically follow it
which is a big part of the story right
but yes they blow up and they Return to
Sender it's a really funny term they use
uh the bombs that come over and it's a
real danger bunny style return to Center
bro you're bringing me a bomb take it
back and sign for it bam you know so
anyway so that's what you're seeing now
it is the strangest morphology you know
shape of a UFO that I've ever seen
jellyfish the jelly and I call it the
jellyfish because of what it did at the
end which I have not provided footage
for yet but it did something it went
trans medium went into the water we'll
talk about that in a sec but the shape
of it let's just talk about that why we
call it the jellyfish some people on
bass were calling it The Spaghetti
Monster right so here's the deal the
jellyfish morphology of UFOs has been
reported since the beginning of UFO
sightings just because you haven't seen
it doesn't mean that that that's a new
thing if you look at like a John Keel
book called operation Trojan Horse one
of the first shapes he lists for known
UFOs is jellyfish the reason that I
dubbed that rather than the spaghetti
monster which was pretty cool is because
it went into the water so what you're
not seeing in the footage I provided and
maybe one day that footage will go
public today is not that day but I will
tell you it does and was filmed and the
object does this it goes out over Lake
cabonia if I'm saying it right it stops
on a dime it descends stiff into the
water and for 17 minutes operators were
told to track the area so they did they
panned out they watched the object does
a controlled us scent up out of the
water after 17 minutes and then shoots
off at 45° it wasn't instantaneous
motion but it was a rapid acceleration
to the point where the camera could
couldn't track it anymore after like 30
mil away that did happen there is
footage of it and I do hope that one day
people get to see that I am not in a
position to release that but I am
testifying to you and take that for
whatever you want that footage exist why
not what are you waiting for
yeah I am going to uh so I don't have
that footage it's not in the safe I'm
going back
what's I don't I I don't have that
footage to provide to the public uh
however I know precisely where it exists
and I will be
informing people within government
exactly where to look people that have
been lied to I will be doing that
straight up and then it's up to them can
they declassify can they get it out but
I will be doing that it's interesting
about the Flying Spaghetti Monster name
because there's a religion that's mostly
tongue and cheek have you ever heard of
it I it's vaguely
yeah it's like their their God is a
flying spaghetti with meatballs for eyes
and so I wonder if maybe there's some
connection where you know someone that's
the reason they named it that Marines
yeah Marines are creative individuals
man so they were like you know but I'll
tell you this what it looked like so the
people that I know that had the closest
uh View and the most direct view as it's
being filmed when you got close into it
it the the things hanging down like the
tendrils or whatever the words the
things that appeared to be hanging down
there it was stiff there was there was
no movement weird they had geometric
attachments it it was a sort of
geometric attachments and the word the
exact words used to describe it to me is
that like like uh armor and scales those
are the two words like scales so
whatever this was was was made it's not
just a bunch of floating
balloons I mean these guys are trained
to know the difference of course
debunker say it's bird on the lens
it's balloons and you know look I can't
shoot out of someone's head so
they just got to live with that but this
is not those things this is a UAP
unidentified anomalous phenomena or UFO
now what it is where it's from what the
intent who made it don't know maybe
there's a terrestrial answer I don't
know yeah I mean we uh what we don't
talk about a lot is the UFOs that are
living under the sea I was just thinking
that same thing they're doing the wi
files yesterday on this it's the
Uso look at you wow and so they
unidentified
submerged and they said it's around the
Bermuda Triangle and and they don't know
what it it's run by but the wifi
Atlantis and it could it could have been
Atlantis but also what was really
fascinating was they had uh Christopher
Columbus his diary he had a sighting
that's right and he had a sighting and
that he said a light was under the water
like there's no lights in 1470
whatever us O's is something that I was
from the highest ranking military
individuals that I've ever spoken with
in private over a decade ago I was urged
to know and understand and look at that
UFOs are one thing unidentified flying
object but Usos are the core of what's
going on that's what was conveyed to me
now why that's important why did we
change it to UAP instead of UFO
unidentified flying object now
unidentified anomalous phenomena okay
here's why because they are what's
called all domain we track UFOs with
satellites pointed outward in space we
track UFOs in air and we track UFOs
under the water all domain space air and
CA unidentified anomalous phenomena
covers all domain so that's why they did
that once something breaches those
different you know areas they call it
trans medium when there's no inertial
effect or they call it trans medium if
it can do that go between all three so
you see no inertial effect which is no
slowdown from space to air to see and a
good example of that would be the Tic
Tac UFO event with Commander David
fraver my good old friend and Buddy and
the guy that filmed it Commander Chad
Underwood it's the most famous UFO case
ever now what people forget is the Tic
Tac UFO wasn't one object it was a
series of weeks of tracking things
dropping from outer space
down to sea level in less than a second
without a sonic boom transm medium no
inertial effect no Sonic Boom so that
was happening during that whole thing of
the Tic Tac UFO event series but
remember this people might not have
caught my first report George and I
broke that story before the New York
Times there was something under the
water for sure there it was docking they
were docking was the word told me was
something a Uso under the water can they
have they tracked them moving at high
speeded underwater yes 100% so there the
resistance of the water isn't an issue
correct is this the one where the Tic
Tac video actually has there are four
more minutes of the video that's the
gimbal I'll explain to you the
difference 2015 was the gimbal 2004 was
the Tic Tac in 2015 was the Gimbal and
the goast those releases the gimbal is
that one that mechanically rotates
Against the Wind and you hear the pilot
saying like holy
120,000 there's a fleet of them yeah
right so what he's saying and I know to
be true is that in that footage where
you see the gimbal rotating it looks
like the Bob Lazar Flying Saucer I mean
it's like shaped like a saucer when it
rotates in front of it is I think five
other objects that were kind of like um
what do you call it when you when you
you go along like a caravan or UFOs or
something escorts right a flock a flock
I don't know what you call like a a
flock ufu a flap um yeah so there there
there were on that day there were other
UFOs in front of that one and there's
four extra minutes of footage that
hasn't been released to the public and
again I'm not in a position to release
that I do believe that if we put enough
pressure maybe the dod and the
government will declassify that and put
it forward that's what we're fighting
for but hell yeah dude that was the
gimbal it's it's a good case what do you
think is the maybe some specul on why
whatever these things driving the crafts
why do they want to be so secretive like
why are they hiding themselves from us
yeah speculation mode right because I I
don't have direct communication with the
aliens you know I don't know who's
operating them but um here's what I
notice what I notice is that the pattern
that we have seen through human history
has been one of observation and not
direct
intervention typically there are cases
of intervention you go all the way back
in history to like Alexander the Great
and like basically like Shields of fire
like beaming down wall to break it
through so he can invade I don't know I
wasn't there that's history right but in
modern history you have these UFOs
landing and communicating with with like
children you have the aerial School
event which is powerful I know the two
girls that were standing right there by
these beings that was in Africa yeah I
keep messing this up the the exact
country that it was uh zimb I think
Zimbabwe it was Rua I don't know I've
been I've been to Africa a bunch man and
I got confused I was just Zimbabwe I
watched a documentary yeah it was
Zimbabwe yeah so so basically the these
um children at the time lisel and Salma
they're incredible human beings they
were like within a meter like three plus
feet of these beings but my point is
this is that there seems to be an
observational program uh that is the
primary thing now some people say that's
prep in the battlefield some people say
they're studying us look we're the
greatest show in the solar system planet
Earth I mean come on man we got it all
war fighting the Kardashians we
got everything right so why wouldn't you
watch us now do you go up to an ant hill
and do you like talk with the ants no
you you know you study them what do you
do to cattle you feed them you water
them you give them antibiotics and then
you eat them so I don't know
what is going on but I do know that
there is direct contact with a lot of
people and what's said to them has kind
of been ubiquitous they they they kind
of repeat the same kind of stuff whoever
these people are that are flying these
things now can we trust what they tell
us oh no man trust is earned and if
you're not revealing yourselves you're
not revealing yourselves the true
architects of the secrecy would be the
visitors themselves you should read a
book called childhood's End by Arthur C
Clark you know who he Arthur C Clark was
a guy like a futurist he like predicted
the Internet it's got some great books
one's called childhood's end and in that
book he's got these craft and what they
do is they post up in the sky and for
Generations they just sit there
acclimate Humanity to their presence
because they got a little dirty secret
that they that they know it's going to
be hard to breach the second they make
humans I don't want to ruin the book but
they look like demons wow so I
don't know why the message that that
aliens that visited that school in
Africa gave to the children was you're
trashing the planet you have to change
this and that was so much before that
was a thing in in humanity right I asked
um lisel one of the two girls like why
do you think you were shown them by the
way it was like a projection in their
minds and it was like mesmerizing like
the the second they turned to their
friends it disappeared so if you believe
them or not it did happen but if you
believe them or not like I asked her why
do you think they said that to you you
know it'd be weird like I don't know
what and if I was an alien I don't know
what I would say to somebody I'd
probably give him a t-shirt or something
why did you say
that what are you supposed to do with
that and then you made a good point it
was so long ago what year was ' 80s
early 80s dude I'm sorry my fact are
scram I'm TI wasn't there like 30 school
children there's a bunch there's a b
yeah full school but so she said to me I
think I'm doing it
now if you ask me anything worth doing
is worth doing now like getting into
therapy and that's why I'm so happy that
this episode is brought to you by better
help what can I say about the benefits
of therapy it helps me keep my
relationship strong and I I happen to
know somebody who recently got into
therapy on better help and it's the
gorgeous Paul brisy yeah I did I got
into it I I got a therapist it was super
easy to set up and even after a few
sessions I felt like I wasn't really
clicking with her it was super easy for
me to switch to a new one I have this
new therap IST I really like and I'm
really enjoying it I like it a lot what
are you working on I'm working on all
sorts of stuff uh my relationship kind
of like what you said like fixing the
roof before it rains um and then just
working on myself trying to be nicer to
myself and a more successful
well-rounded human
being there you have it you heard it
from Paul you heard it from me and I'm
sure that you can think of a bunch of
stuff that you could work on yourself
and it's never been easier you go to
betterhelp.com
SLO that's better
hp.com SLO and use the promo code steo
for 10% off your first month there it is
you can work on everything you can be a
better happier healthier version of
yourself so one more time do it by going
to
betterhelp.com
steo and using the promo code steo now
let's get back to it I go what do you
mean she goes just talking about it yeah
I think that was the point spreading the
word spread the word the other thing it
makes me think of is that old Twilight
Zone from the 60s where they find the
book that the aliens had to serve man
was the name of the book they translated
it and then they were working on
translating what was inside of it and
they're like oh they're here to help us
and at the end the famous line is it's a
cookbook no to serve man dude will you
will you text me that episode uh you the
title of it like ser oh my God I I
really hope we're not food man and by
the way you taste better than me so go
with him first man I just like yeah I
don't want to be eaten by no alien let
let me ask you this um you when we talk
about the you know encounters beings and
and that yeah
the the physical
appearance seems to be uh pretty
consistent where like like we we hear um
these beings referred to as Grays yeah
yeah and and it's like the most
stereotypical like the big large eyes
the tiny mouth and nose like the little
kind of Elf sort of uh thin like that
like that uh I I I feel like I want to
believe that that's just sort of a hokey
like
stereotype however it would seem that
credible there there's some credibility
to how uh widely consistent that is
where you're standing that is the
popular understanding of what the beings
might look like is the spindly 3 and 1/2
fet to 4 feet gray aliens with big
wraparound eyes and big heads very
little features as if it's a human being
that's evolved without the need for
speech or to eat the same way MH where
I'm standing I mean in my email like
pull it up right now it's like it's like
a slot machine of encounters and it is
not the only structural type of this
visitor that I I see everything and more
under the rainbow dude it's it's like
beings that look just like us 8 foot
tall there's like these uh reptilian
ones that people report this is
throughout history right um there's the
Mantis looking ones there's the tall
grades the short grades I mean I I was
told by by people who who I trust have
more knowledge than
me that there is a cacophony of Life out
there just outside of our Earth and
every type of kind of thing that could
be created with Biology has been created
and and and some are more advanced than
others and some likely are visiting here
so I I don't know but you're right now
that image was kind of popularized by
like the encounters by Betty and Barney
Hill which is the first modern abductees
although it was happening for so long
you know they kind of came out forward
into the public and also this guy
Whitley streber wrote a book I think
called uh contact or commun communion
communion yeah and you know so he had
that that image on the cover so the
answer that I have to that although I
don't know if I have many answers but
it's that you're hearing something
something that you see in kind of the
popular culture I am being reported to
on a daily basis for over a decade a
much wider variety of species of
visitor I am an untrusting person until
you've earn my trust though I don't
believe I think people can make you see
if I put on some kind of weird mask
and roll up on you you're going to think
I'm someone else right so I think there
might be an element of that and jock
ballet a real deep thinker on this
subject he wrote a book and on the cover
is like this masked alien that has these
different like the jester face and all
this we might en be
encountering what they want us to see
them as that makes sense to me and it
could be weirder than that yeah I read
the book uh project serpo you're you're
familiar with it yeah and I'm I was
convinced it was real but when I was
talked to you about it last time you
like oh yeah the fantasy book I'm like
it's a fantasy but it's uh you know I
mean how true is that because you talk
about what Al and tari and the two sons
and they had these documented people
that went there and and it was kind of
like a hitchhiker Guide to the Galaxy
where in a sense where it they would go
to the stop that planet was like a
stopping ground for the entire galaxy
and they describe different alens coming
in and out sometimes they look like us
sometimes they look like gray sometimes
they look like all different I mean are
is there any truth to any of the project
serpo yeah I mean so again it's just an
opinion from some bearded guy right but
it's like uh
I know some of the people involved in
that era and I know that current day I
have provided evidence that I've decided
to not release to the public because I
know that it has been tainted through
protection programs of like black budget
programs trying to influence uh
falsehoods put forward but they smartly
what they do is they wrap in it some
truth so when there were like the leaks
of the mj12 documents famously back in
the day in the UFO World some of that
information
ACC so and even
today a lot of what I end up obing I
need to be very cautious that there
could be some like I recognize that
program name the public does not know
that program name doesn't mean what I
read on that page with the program name
on it is real information I have been
shown what are alleged to be classified
documents and indeed are classified
documents like you know you could back I
could backtrack that and find out but
that doesn't mean that what's on that
page is correct information so you have
to be very careful so project serpo
there are elements of Truth to that I
can't distinguish which ones but there
are elements I'm just they sent up 12
people they I don't know bro I don't
know I just don't know the answer to
that as far as uh what aliens look like
like the way I think about it is on
Earth Here intelligent life you know we
have us shaped like this two arms two
legs head on top then there's octopus
that are nothing like us and then you
even a dolphin being a mammal looks so
different than us that it seems absurd
that anything coming from another planet
would look anything like us do you makes
me think the time travel thing with the
standard alien do you know how to feed a
baby
panda bamboo I can teach you man you get
in a panda suit and you go feed it oh I
see where you're going with that yeah
man so I don't trust for one second you
know the the look of what the true form
is being hidden come on on man I could
put a mask on you that you can't even
see close up isn't you so I just like
the thing is with this the whole UFO
thing is I don't know man I don't know
what's true from them whoever they are
um I try to get things that I can sink
my teeth into that we can then have a
discussion about so video evidence is
great but the big questions we can't
even start on that until our government
comes clean there today just today there
was a classified briefing they were
waiting for to find out is David grush
telling you the truth I saw the newsp a
big deal and I was shocked I'm getting
some texts from you know Congressional
people and they're telling me okay they
were able to validate some stuff they
didn't completely Stonewall us now I
haven't had those calls yet because
Steve rolls up with you guys but that
was today and so I'm I'm hopeful that
they got more information but here's the
rub or not the rub here's the Ace in the
Hole the Inspector General of the United
States
I know some of what you've been briefed
on because I literally sent people your
way instead of to arrow and the the UFO
program because I don't trust them
anymore they got a new director could be
good let's find out Sean kpatrick didn't
you know he OB fiscated to the American
public but the new director really hope
that he's a good guy here he is I sent
people to the
iig encouraged them to fill out
whistleblower complaints direct
eyewitness who work on these programs I
know that that individual is briefed on
them so in that conversation that he
just had today I'm hoping he did offer
some of that truth because if not these
people they're locked they're ready
they're done done with being oppressed
with this and they're going to come
forward so I really hope that
information is being presented properly
to Congress oh that sounded like a
threat oh I'm full of threats man
but really like I'm a teddy bear I like
make a threat and walk away like I don't
want to fight you know um the uh the the
2B series um like one thing that really
really kind of moved me a little bit was
um the people who have had encounters I
don't want to classify them as alien
abductions but people who have been
visited by beings yeah yeah I saw that
part I I did see that very cool yeah
people who have been visited by beings
guy J right and and they feel like they
can't they can't share this with anybody
because because they're going to be uh
labeled as crazy they might lose their
job they might they they might you
know get divorced or whatever like they
just feel like there there's a sadness
about having this experience that you
can't share honestly and um that that
what in that section of the show they
talked about again like the the
consistency of the account of all of
these visits yeah Y and so I I want to
ask like
what what do you consider uh the most
credible like kind of
official uh account of one of these
visits uh I mean so there's the Betty
and Barney Hill case which is really
powerful incredible if you really
understand why um that how that came out
why it came out I find that to be a very
very credible case with physical
evidence and and radar and all this
stuff Travis Walton and that would be my
second one is Travis Walton and he has
this incredible account look his friends
were looking at going to jail they
thought they that that they killed him
when he was missing and he was missing
for a number of days he pops back up now
not everything about Travis do I know to
be true but I that event is the most
kind of fascinating as one that I would
say you should really look at Travis
Walton Betty and Barney Hill but I mean
I get wait wait Betty and Barney were
their names was that before The
Flintstones and that's why the
Flintstones name this ain't the Jetson
man yeah it's Flintstones but it it
interesting because like wait a second
Betty and Barney Barney well no I'm
wondering which came first like chicken
of the egg I don't know they're actual
names was it in the 50s or something
yeah so look uh right there came first
yeah Betty and Barney Hill is they must
have that must been a little like nod to
that in the cartoon and eventually an
alien did visit the cartoon I can't
remember that little you got some weird
ass memory you tell me all these cool
things I don't know you got to inform me
man why have you not been informing me
of these cool things all the TV shows
that had an alien buddy like Mor from
orc or Al or um My Favorite Martian and
even like I Dream of Genie I always felt
like she was possibly an alien well ET
ET and every single time they got to
hide the alien yeah they got to hi yeah
on their own that's their own person
personal choice they're like this is
only for me well look if if I'm going to
slip so like documentar like I'm reading
here actually on the screen like Zeta
reticuli incident that's that's super
interesting
because there are things that repeat
themselves so like even Bob Lazar if you
go back to like kind of my gateway drug
into UFOs was this guy bobazar so I I
made this movie bobazar Area 51 and
flying saucers and I'm I'm proud of that
movie because for me it took many years
but what it was was me trying to get to
the truth on this is this guy a liar or
is he telling it as it is uh I can tell
you now I know that he is telling it as
it is what he's saying to you is
accurate correct and true it happened to
him he was shown a bunch of stuff about
the aliens like in like WR written form
so he's really good about it he's like I
put my hands on the propulsion system I
know that's real now they told me a
bunch of stuff and they showed me
documents with a bunch of stuff he goes
it's words on paper Jeremy I I I don't
know but this is what they told me one
of the things they told him was that
these beings that made these craft and
gave him cool names like um not
spaghetti M you gave names like the
sport model that's the one he worked on
they told him that was from Zeta
reticuli and and the exact and the exact
uh planet of that star system right so I
just saw the Betty in Barney Hill I
guess they mentioned Zeta reticuli so
that's a common theme yeah I up
project Sero was Zeta reticuli as well
really yeah so there there's often times
disinformation with real information
I've noticed that like so not to be
cruel but like hey you intelligence
agents I know who you are people contact
me and they'll give me a good piece of
information real legitimate like a
source then I come to find
out what agencies they work for what not
I use my spies and and it turns out they
start trying to feed me false
information so that's the game that's
always played the best way to get you to
believe something fake is to seat it
with real information too yeah but like
even with the Travis Walton story they
all pass the LI detector like five
separate times Yeah man so like yeah but
those things you just put a tack in your
shooting I mean I don't know would know
got one I've been practicing on for like
two years I don't know do you have a lot
of people reaching out to you that are
just cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs and you have
to filter them out like
predominantly besides my family who are
the worst um yeah yeah of course man you
you know look UFOs and the subject is so
so big it draws in the the crazy or
draws out the crazy from people we all
want to believe something right so of
course man but I I don't want to like
on it and people like I enjoy
getting the descriptions whether I
believe them or not or can prove them or
not I really do enjoy hearing what
people have experienced of course
there's a wide range I mean sometimes
I've referred people to Medical uh
people like in a nice like I have people
like at a major university
who want to study individuals that have
delusions about the UFO phenomenon
compared to real events to see why
that's a popular culture thing there's a
university major university is doing
that so I'll push people to them when
appropriate yeah 5150 these people I
don't do anything I just don't answer
emails I thought it was a a pretty
uh
major claim that the government
um
prioritizes UAP yeah more than weapons
of mass destruction like they consider
uh you know alien activity to be a
bigger threat than nuclear war well
those the nuclear warheads have been
disarmed by correct by aliens so yeah I
mean that puts them above yeah the we
we've had you said that we the that uh
our nuclear programs have been turned
turned off and turned on Yeah by both in
Russia and the United States mstom Air
Force base in the United States and
multiple bases in the 60s and Russia
George nap smuggled documents back can
never go back to Russia George uh from
the UFO programs during glassos and
perista in the early 90s and I believe
we did cover this the first time we
spoke with you uh to to some degree but
we
asked um the making of like the
Oppenheimer the the atom bomb and and
and I think we we asked whether uh UAP
phenomena kicked up when we got maybe
even kicked off when when we got into
kicked up not kicked off yeah okay well
they started Alamos right where he was
making the bomb right and that's where
the Roswell 1947 crash was in the paper
New Mexico since the beginning of the
atomic program the influx of observation
by UAP or UFOs uh has increased
obviously we have very powerful weapons
that could destroy the Earth maybe the
Earth is precious maybe that's why the
kids get that message maybe that's why
we get an influx UFOs maybe that's why
they show us they can turn on or off as
a display of power our nuclear weapons
so that we don't up and like the
match that really kind of checks out
with me because like it seems evident
that there's nothing hostile about the
the UAP overtly hostile I agree right
because if they wanted to kick our ass
they would and we have no no way to
defend even the government seems to
acknowledge that and so the idea of
Earth being precious and them wanting to
preserve the Earth uh would would seem
the most likely or we're
containers like you don't go and beat up
your cattle before you eat them so so
I'm just saying there's two I don't know
the answer I'm saying there's two sides
of the coin I lean with you I'm an
optimist I kind of lean with you they
want to us up they us up
however we don't really know the intent
and so you just have to be open to the
and that I get it that's the military's
point of view too they could be our
creators they could be essentially Our
God and they were their little
experiment or they're just like a kid
and this is their little like guinea pig
cage okay let me ask you this um the
speculation that it was aliens who built
the pyramids who did built Stonehenge
who we talked about that on the last
episode I remember I'm kind of like not
as knowledgeable in that or don't feel
like you know I speak from personal um
opinion but I I will say this even
without the ancient history modernday
history George knp and I did an episode
on weaponized he got this guy who wrote
um the day after Roswell and it was an
old who checked out and he did have the
roles he did and he said he seeded our
industry with technology from the UFOs I
really believe that yeah that was his
claim what's seated mean seed means like
you propagate it to 150 years ago we
didn't have anything and now look at us
there's that's such a short amount of
time for how much technology we've just
suddenly like and then it' be like one
guy like you know like Tesla invents all
this stuff or I think they just implant
it into these people and they're like oh
just give that person he'll spread the
word to the rest of humanity and they'll
have some more technology I I don't know
but yeah no and I I I think it's a
really cool idea and and here's
the here's the deal though like even
without ancient stuff even without
pyramids and all that like although it
is pretty suspect the idea there's
pyramids in Africa and in South America
don't get me started because this is not
my thing but yeah like I you know it's a
it's a subject to talk about going on
there but we don't even have to look
back to ancient times right if we
understand with Colonel Coro and what he
reported to us when he was running these
programs was that they seeded or put
this in this technology into industry
now the thing is we can look at modern
day we know our United States government
with a joint Allied group of foreign
materials program called the five eyes
foreign materials program are reverse
engineering UFO technology we know they
are doing that so now there's there's a
supportive document and I
mean look into that foreign materials
program from the five eyes right so if
we are reverse engineering and the DIA
is reverse engineering this and
other corporations like locked Martin
and Bae and all these companies if
they're doing it then they are
definitely get
derivative Technologies to bring even
into the skins of our stealth craft or
whatever so they're doing it now we can
look to the pyramids it's being done now
what is
that what was he talking about on the uh
on the show I think it was episode one
where he's was saying yeah if you look
at the Moon there's that crater and
there's a six mile high antenna talking
about John le what the yeah is that
real so you got a glimpse in into the
craziness that I started in to get
involved with UFOs in episode one you
saw episode one yep okay so I when
they're talking about my life that's
Lear jet John Lear yeah they say well I
think they kind of say like Jeremy kind
of started you know doing with this guy
John leir filming with this guy so this
is the son of William peer William peer
was the inventor of the eight track uh
cassette tape or stereo he motra Ola is
a company that was built off of his
company um he invented the Lear Jet and
his dad was a force of Nature and he
also was involved with UFO stuff but his
son John kind of was the disinherited
son like the will I read the will it was
like basically his dad gave him a can of
dog food when he died and every line
says except for John Lear like so
everybody gets this except for John le
they didn't have a good relationship but
John leer is the most wild bastard I
ever met I I I I loved him like a family
member I started filming about UFOs
thinking he's my gateway drug he's the
way for me to get in right um at the end
of his life he he and I he disliked me
very much and I still loved him um he
was a wild man though and so that's how
I got started he told me a bunch of
stuff and no most of it's complete
nonsense he talked about like
you know however many 98 races on the
surface of the Sun I mean it was almost
like he's testing you to see if you're a
total idiot M but some of the stuff he
told me
checked out and validated it's like if
you have no filter and everybody gives
you UFO stuff because you're John le you
know the son of William P Le and you
don't have a filter and you spew it all
out at people he did that to me and what
I got over all those years of filming
with him is certain things that I found
out were
true and like like Bob lazar's
employment at site for reverse
engineering UFOs so a lot of the leads
that I got were great but that's what
you see in episode one of the 2B series
is kind of how I started into the foo
thing with that guy John leer The
Godfather of conspiracy you know with
John le um why did he you know sour on
you near the end of his life did you
expose him or something or no I didn't
expose him I I loved him I I cared for
him um I ultimately the truth of the
matter is that his family made it
completely impossible for me to make the
film after I think he like ended up
signing something on a napkin after I
had set up my whole years of filming
with him giving all the rights to a
family member who then trying to extort
me I mean it was like ridiculous I just
pieced out on that so I think he really
wanted me to make the movie on him and I
ended up making it on Bob Lazar but
that's because he made it impossible for
me to make the movie on him got it yeah
I I I did care for him and there's a lot
of kind of you know he'll he was kind of
pissed at the end but like you know we
had a run together and the so I I think
we left on okay terms when he died yeah
um if aliens are trying to protect the
Earth are they doing a pretty bad
job we're still
here right but
uh does it feel like uh you know like
World War II like crazy like just kind
of imminent stuff and and uh the the
fact of the the one thing being filmed
in Iraq like Iraq was like the river
Tigris and Euphrates like the first
civilization Sumeria like and then a t
like that's like a major like Hub of
we're seeing them everywhere the the
reason why like the Baghdad Phantom I
put out from Iraq the mosa orb from Iraq
and then also this one the jellyfish
right U there's one I also later in the
series called the chandelier I release
and that's over the Persian Gulf so in
that area the reason you're just seeing
a lot is because those are active
conflict zones with a lot of monitoring
systems and then that is current and so
a lot of that stuff comes to me and I
feel comfortable releasing that but
there is footage from even within so
this will mess you up and I think I
mentioned the series The reason I took
the jellyfish UFO seriously is because I
have direct firsthand knowledge of a
video from pantex I think that's in
Texas it's one of our nuclear Armament
and disarmament facilities
one of the most secretive facilities we
have in a lot of ways of a jellyfish UFO
jellyfish morphology UFO coming in down
between the nuclear silos making a pass
through like a corridor and then popping
up and shooting off at 45 degrees with
instantaneous movement so I was already
attuned to the idea that this shape of
UFO moving and seemingly doing some sort
of surveillance or reconnaissance of
military bases is something that has
happened recently and in many places so
you're just hearing about Iraq you know
because that's where we have the
capability of documenting not only that
but they're also there to check it out
the aliens are looking at it and we have
whoever these things but also remember I
released so 2004 Tic Tac UFO that was
west coast of California 2015 gimal and
goest that was East Coast I have reports
that I I actually talked about it it was
uh in uh off the coast of Japan the
South Asian Sea swarms UFOs I released
radar thermal infrared and deck footage
from 2019 with 10 warships being swarmed
simultaneously by over 100 UFOs I
provided all of that footage it was
confirmed by the Pentagon so man look
it's happening everywhere all the time
all around you you know you know just
just hearing you say those things it
makes me realize a lot of them sound
like they're around big bodies of water
is that is are there more UFO sightings
Usos dog yeah dog Usos um but not the
only ones but I'm talking about either
above or below the surface of the US
dog saying there more activity near
coastal areas there's a Preposterous
preponderance of
reports showing that the water is really
important when it comes to the um maybe
maybe that's where they go okay let's
just try this maybe that's where they go
to chill now let me say why think it's
so simple I mean people have talked
about this it's not a new idea but if
you are going between Star systems and
planets right you have to worry about
what like heat and pressure and
atmosphere right so you got some craft
what is going to be the same anywhere in
the Galaxy pretty much the same if you
have liquid water it has to be within a
very narrow temperature and there's
going to be a very narrow amount of
pressure depending on the depth of that
water so if I was a space fairing
civilization visiting other planets I
would look for waterm Sweet let's go
park our craft there we know the
temperature we know the pressure so that
could be why water has always played a
role in lakes and oceans and they are
absolutely reported coming in and out of
the water all the time but they're also
in their our skies they're also in space
we have great High Fidelity satellite
video and imagery of UFOs full craft and
full ship that are not released to the
public but do exist captured by our
satellites when Neil Armstrong came back
from the Moon I mean I know there's
going to be so many people that are
on this but like there is that
like recording of Buzz aldr and Neil
Armstrong they saw that thing that was
following them and they were like
disgusting internally like dude how what
the are we even going to say you
know what I'm talking about I I have an
astronaut story you know yeah there's a
lot of both Russian and US astronauts
who have contacted me directly and some
are public about what it is they they've
talked about some of recordings have
been leaked some of it's fake on the
internet some of the things are fake um
I will say this I spent a lot of time
with a sixth man who walked on the moon
his name is Dr Edgar Mitchell and before
he died uh I filmed with him the last
filming anybody ever did with him I did
three days with him I and I traveled
with him for a little bit there he is uh
this dude was that that's how we know
about the the wilson d Davis memo which
you guys like is too nerdy to get into
but this is a guy that knew
and with beyond a shadow of a doubt he
was informed on UFO reverse engineering
programs straight up yes astronauts will
maybe sometimes see things but I don't
know I wasn't there but I've heard the
same thing as you yeah I friend's a
pilot for a major airlines and I'm like
don't don't you you're probably you
probably see aliens sometimes or
something or something that looks like
it he's like no we have the shades down
most of the time yeah except all the
pilots calling me now have started
buying GoPros and sticking them on their
Windows because I have video footage
from Pilots over the last 3 months of
the most anomalous moving in front
of them that they have gotten so they
were like we need sensor packages call
Bob Lazaro ask him what we need to put
CU he's like person for their personal
use yeah see there's a there's a dirty
little space here which is that are they
going to be in trouble filming out the
window while they're flying these are
commercial airline pilots so we're
trying to figure out what the legality
is of that and some people say like my
buddy Ryan Graves runs that you Aeros or
you know safety flight thing when it
comes to Aviation and they got this cool
Reporting System they're putting
together are they going to get in
trouble because you can hear what flight
they're on and I have tons of video
we're just trying to decide can we put
it out to be analyzed I mean I'll show
it to you it's tons of video from
different Pilots all around the United
States and the world who do you talk to
about you talk to a a a Aerospace lawyer
like I know who who the FAA not they
have to yeah policy has to change or
they should just put cameras on all
flights and feed them live right into
the cockpit and also to everybody that's
sitting there imagine that you want to
see UFOs I would get on a flight if an
airline advertised Galactic Federation
flights here we go you're going to have
in front of you six camera view all
around the plane look for UFOs while
you're on our flight to Brazil I mean
it' be so cool well
watching that would be cool yeah is
there any other speculation that maybe
is Life on Mars I was thinking about
that when you were talking about the
water because they say that there's
probably was water back at one point in
history and yeah but I haven't really
heard much lately about people it used
to be all the time martians don't hear
that very much and maybe the visitors
were trying to play us on that and
venuti right but um I will send you a
document that that uh is public it was
by the CIA that will really blow your
mind about that so you remind me I'll
text it to you thanks the um reverse
engine engineering it like if the
technology is so Advanced like is there
any hope for accomplishing anything
trying to reverse engineer it and does
anybody running these reverse
engineering programs have any idea of
what they're actually like aiming at
yeah and uh you know like you say it's
game over whoever does it first but like
does anybody even know what the what the
goal is yeah the goal is to uh up our
game with Material Science so we can
create what they call metam materials
which are like Alloys that have a a
different effect in their environments
when you when they're man-made or
human-made or made by an intelligence
I've got an example in my house I can
show you and you can feel a physical
effect it's really pretty wild it's
called graphine what they're trying to
do is get the material science to the
level where we could duplicate the not
only the engines of these machines the
technology because we understand how
they work pretty much but gravity
propulsion yeah that's the everybody
believes it that's how it is but matter
is the only thing that produces gravity
as as far as we know it or shows us the
effects of gravity but these reportedly
actually produce gravity that's what
bobazar said back in the day and produce
energy too like it was speculated in the
uh series that if if we do manage the
reverse uh engineering if we do kind of
uh get uh capable on the level of this
thing then all of a sudden like oil is
no longer needed like energy like like
uh they were producing energy
without without issue then so like that
poses a threat to the whole fossil fuel
industry to the yeah I've heard that
I've heard that for a long time and I
don't think Society has the
infrastructure to immediately change to
a new form of energy we'd have to be
able to replicate the devices to create
this maybe it's not just a principle of
the universe but it's also Material
Science challenge so I don't think the
world would change immediately I don't
think that's why there's secrecy oh
throw down industry are you kidding me
theyd look at that they'd be like oh
yeah let's make money on that so there
would be a way to monetize it now people
would disagree with me for sure a lot of
people disagree with me that that we
have reverse engineered UFOs people say
I'm like cool man show me one so I don't
know how far we've gotten Bob Lazar said
we couldn't get anywhere everybody I've
ever talked to said we can barely get
anywhere on this because we can't
reproduce the physical materials however
one day we will one day we will be able
to and then we'll see how it changes
industry all right what are the next
steps with the government do we have any
more big hearings coming up are they
gonna release more than nine pages of uh
of anything like right that one today
right there's one today was big
apparently I haven't talked to everybody
that was there but there was some
information you know look it's it's baby
steps man this doesn't like I wish I
could kick open the door and there you
go even just just putting out new
footage it's baby steps controversy but
what is the hope steo I mean that's the
deal right what's the
hope I can tell you for sure that it's
going to be easy way or hard way meaning
I would like to see the slow process of
the National Defense authorization act
they they have some things in place now
for UFOs I'd like to see it work that
way for people to go to the Inspector
General of intelligence for people to be
protected for NASA to catch up they're
not even allowed to study classified
stuff they have to only use public
domain stuff I would like to see this
happen in a controlled manner but an
uncontrolled manner the hard way might
be the other option what I mean by that
is more leaks of videos that are even
higher
Fidelity more people coming forward that
will risk their positions in current
jobs in agencies or even their pensions
or even their clearances and they'll put
it on the line and they'll talk right in
front to Congress in open Congressional
hearings all of that all of that is
going to happen if our intelligence
agencies and our The Gatekeepers of this
information don't provide a a a
legitimate legal and safe process for
people to bring this information forward
people are frustrated and I'll tell you
that for sure so easy way or hard way
it's going to happen not tomorrow not
the next day but it's not going to take
forever and you know I already know
because people are they're ready I've
actually recorded with folks you know
that I will put that out when they say I
can so it it's coming man you know
whatever this is and we'll figure it out
we'll adapt last
question um did
Mexico
acknowledge that their big reveal of
their little Mexican uh aliens
that like there lackluster right was it
the bodies like like what was your like
what's the final word on that like
finish episode two they blew it finish
episode two so yeah so you've watched uh
episode one and half of episode two I'm
close to the end of episode two okay I
think that they go through what I think
I make some strong words about that and
you know we'll see how that goes uh
episode three I I can't wait for you to
see because I show um the the chandelier
UAP a completely different from from
these classified archives from what I
understand um this this other strange uh
image from a video so so here's the deal
watch the series I do a bad job because
it's just I I don't I didn't even watch
it myself in fully yet but it you know
on Tu watch it because that that third
episode there's another bombshell and we
do get into that Mexico alien thing they
get well into it in episode to yeah I I
read I haven't watched that whole thing
yet but I read on Reddit where someone
was had just watched it and they said it
was so satisfying how um the Mexican
mummy aliens were dealt with were dealt
with yeah because we want to you really
you did the did it justice nice and
that's you know I think uh Ryan Graves
was there and I think it was like he was
um kind of shocked he said I felt punked
yeah I I saw that part yeah um I my
question was um has the Mexican
Government acknowledged like have they
said uh our bad okay but but but
remember it's not the Mexican Government
putting it out it's UFO researchers that
are look I'll give you the skinny on
this that I haven't said before ever
which is that I was approached many many
years ago to be like the face of the
mummies I'm like who the are you
I'm like what are you talking about so
look I don't know dude I haven't done
analysis but let me tell you it doesn't
look like Tasty Cake here's the deal
there's other things we should be
focusing on and those things are real
and they're happening now you look at at
the news in Senate and Congress you see
what's going on the language that was
put forward to rip out control of these
UFO programs from from the people that
are holding it that's real and that was
informed and it didn't pass completely
how we wanted but it they wrote it and
they wrote it for a reason so we are now
in a new age where we can have this
conversation and some people laugh they
maybe they just don't get it we're
seeing things like this but ultimately
um the stuff I'm putting out I hope
moves the needle forward this
conversation will be different you know
in 6 months8 months than we're having
right now because I know certain things
are coming and there's going to be more
people like David grush and David grush
will expand on what he said and and what
he can testify to so it's it's exciting
times to be a human being on planet
Earth right yeah what is there that just
Everyday People Like Us could do to push
forward and get more things revealed is
there something that we can do to help
yeah man we are all Everyday People
we're all doing this just because people
call me doesn't mean that other people
don't have power man you know what you
do is you get loud you ask questions you
ask for reports um you know if you find
somebody that's got something really
interesting send it to me if you know
people in the military that are having
encounters and you know they they can I
am I am able to receive anything from
anybody so what people can do is they
can talk about it they can normalize it
they can reduce the stigma and most
importantly they can just pay attention
if you pay attention with an open mind
you'll see what's going on it is deep
what's happening and so I think that's
the number one thing we need to bring
this into pop culture in a way where
we're having the right
conversation all right yeah well dude
been a wild ride dude it's an epic wild
ride dude I love you bro and uh there
your first episode was such a Crusher
man I I I hope this one uh gets as much
love Yeah man well now now we're talking
about more so people should definitely
watch this one yeah thanks for letting
me be a part of it too this is awesome
great daying love you bro love you too
on guys and there you have it ladies and
gentlemen the triumphant return of the
great Jeremy Corbell um I hope you guys
enjoyed that as much as I did and I'd
like to point out that after the first
episode we did with him I thought man
that's the greatest job I ever did as
the host of The Wild Ride podcast and
sure enough I saw some comment about how
I totally blew it and I when wrote like
a big thoughtful response to this person
I thought man you know what here's the
thing he can never make everybody happy
he can't and uh like I said at the
beginning of this episode caught a lot
of flak a lot of negative feedback for
our previous episode the one about Cat
Williams and Aaron
Rogers and again man like we got it
wrong okay we got it wrong got a lot of
negative feedback um yeah we admitted we
got it wrong and you move on I'm happy
to report I lost no sleep over it didn't
even change the tiple
and so I leave that with you this week
remember you're never going to make
everybody happy like try to be the best
you you can admit when you're wrong
improve from it but don't let the
bastards get you
down I love you
guys